olá pessoal aqui este rico maior
privilégio do mundo para falar um pouco
da minha experiência tenho muito a dizer
nossa ponte com os arma já eu vim para
equipar e há uns anos atrás mas qualquer
atleta com mais de 20 anos vêm com o
trabalhador
trabalhei nas obras públicas trabalhei
no ciman trabalhei em várias áreas mas
também um apaixonado pela terra
com o passar dos anos a fio a band que a
terra mais importante de todas as outras
coisas que podemos observar na nossa
própria pessoa
olhamos a volta vem verdura vemos algo
vamos todos os componentes que
precisamos para ser felizes e van
tentar dizer que no dedo profissão
comecei a trabalhar na terra ea schoch e
tem uma necessidade tramanda poderão
encher trabalho com a terra trabalho com
as matérias orgânicas fossa biológico
para poder consumir minimamente
realizada villégier produzir preparar o
solo de estúdio também poderá dar e
vender e fazer com que possamos ser mais
feliz mais e dava e é isso que nós
queremos chegar falo por mim próprio nos
químicos difícil
o mágico de oz possível estudar a
matéria que estamos e qatar para o
santos
haja imaginação haja muita vontade de
trabalhar e incentivar qualquer
cerimônia nesta prova ou seja se gosta
da terres quer comer um produto e ser
fluidez e dalva trabalhar um pacto por
e aí os pleitos warton resultado
positivo é o benefício a partida
consegui usar mais oito fria de sinusite
fria doutores musculares têm algum
stress ea vida da minha mudança do do
trabalho que trabalhar os irmãos têm que
trabalhar e ver para a terra ea terra da
felicidade seja tanto pela terra e até
digamos mais a minha saída está sempre
por santi porque suei conseguimos mais
produtos consigo controlar o bafta meio
eo bem estar da terra eo bem estar das
plantas seguindo a minha experiência já
dá alguns 15 aos provável mantidos nesta
coisa da terra com visto de turista
desafia todo o seu irmão que possa
cantar um voz seja o furo e plantar
semear fazer uns cães nada especial
é maravilhoso e depois já tinham sido
todos porque uma flor uma planta nativa
que ser para a caminha para ela
atividades da guarda é esta vida é muito
lento muito leite
estamos a viver um século que as pessoas
têm gravados por kimi koopas coisas mais
facilitadas para as máquinas e uma
ambientação franja é um desafio e uma
juntando para um privilégio que deitem
que se uma vaga gastarem as mangas e
tiverem o privilégio poder fazer fala
que é grande e ficar alta novamente
nosso convite para que toda a gente que
acha que trabalhar e tem alguma vontade
da sustentabilidade da terra
não há necessidade
químicos seja quem for para ter lá uma
qualidade de vida ou a qualidade do sal
e acima de preparar o o ambiente por um
futuro próximo para nossa nova geração
os está sendo difícil incutir nas
pessoas e prepará las para que possam
ver que realmente o mundo não precisa de
químicos mas sim de gente trabalhadora
pessoas interessadas em melhorar o
ambiente e acima de tudo preparar as
pessoas para que o mantém alguma
sustentabilidade numa edição estamos
felizes e alegres khan
os hospitais são calorosos de jantar com
algumas doenças de sabemos muito bem
daquela são derivadas agradeceu o
convite e mais uma vez lanço um desafio
para que quem quiser e tem essa data da
contratação e não gosta
criamos o velho em uma das coisas que
temos de buscar sair da terra e na terra
temos por nosso constante e fico muito
agradecido e também de obrigada